Yeah,
president of American grand strategy
basically says nuclear weapons could
only be possessed by countries that we
like and they cannot be possessed by cut
trees we don't like.
So if Katrina's we don't like try and
get nuclear weapons,
we will move heaven and earth to stop
the.
That's the basic story.
I was a codicil to that.
We basically would prefer that no other
countries get nuclear weapons either
because it just complicates our lives
right now.
In a perfect world,
it would be nice if there were no other
nuclear weapons states except the United
States right there.
There were already several other nuclear
weapons states other than the United
States.
We've learned how to live with other
nuclear weapons states.
Right,
and if you look at the kinds of policies
than it takes to keep other powers from
doing in their national security
interests inside their own border with
their own money,
what it is they conceive as being
necessary for their national security to
try and dictate to them what they can
and cannot do is a big job and you need
a hedgematic position to be able to do
with that.
You need decisive,
crushing military superiority,
and you may even need to be able to
invade them right,
and if you look at the arguments about
Iran and about North Korea as they've
unfolded over the last 10 years and as
are being discussed today,
right?
The question lurking in the background
all the time is if you can't get them to
negotiate away these capabilities,
which they seem to want for their own
reasons,
you should be willing to fight a
preventive war,
not a preemptive war,
not attacking them before they attack
you when you think they're getting ready
to attack you,
but attacking them now because you think
there might be a problem later and you'd
rather not deal with it.
So you're going to have war now to avoid
some kind of war later.
Right,
and that seems pretty good if the war is
cheap,
but the wars are not cheap,
right?
Because rubbing out another country's
nuclear weapons is turns out to be a big
job.
You've got to destroy factories,
laboratories.
You've got to wreck their economy.
You've got to keep the economy squeeze.
You have to kill people or get or kidnap
them,
scientists,
engineers,
right?
If you want to prevent a moderately
technologically advanced country,
and here we're talking about North
Korea,
which is really nothing special from
getting this old technology of nuclear
weapons.
It's no an old technology.
It's not a mystery,
right?
You really need to be able to to,
to get your,
your hands around their neck and squeeze
it and keep squeezing.
Right?
So the question is,
how many times with how many places are
you willing to do this?
How often are you willing to wage
preventive wars?
How many countries do you want to be at?
A constant,
this kind of relationship with,
right?
These are the questions you have to ask
to help.
If we had an.
I'd like to have an honest debate about
this.
The United States,
right?
I don't even think we have an honest
debate because the way,
the way the debate has happened is it
will be very bad if they got nuclear
weapons.
We have to do something about it.
All options are on the table.
What kind of euphemism is all options
are on the table wars on the table?
Well,
what kind of wars on the table?
How many wars are on the table?
What are the likelihood of success?
What are the unintended consequences of
war to prevent nuclear proliferation?
All right.
These are questions we should debate.
We should ask.
We should answer right now.
My problem with nuclear weapons is
rather different.
I believe that America knows how to
deter countries to have nuclear weapons.
Countries that have nuclear weapons are
not going to attack the United States
because if they do,
we're going to annihilate them.
It will be very sad for us.
It will be even sadder for them,
right?
They're mostly small nuclear powers.
We are graded large nuclear power,
right?
The whole thing would be very,
very,
very sad and tragic and it's easy for
the other side to know how tragic it's
going to be because our nuclear forces
are not a secret,
right?
We have 1500 warheads on a variety of
delivery systems and we can wreck pretty
much any country in the world,
right?
That's the residual of our Cold War
force and we are getting ready to spend
a trillion dollars modernizing that for
us to keep it tip top shape.
I think deterrence we can do so.
What do I worry about?
I worry about not nuclear weapons in the
hands of states,
but nuclear weapons that are not in the
hands of states.
I worry about nuclear weapons that are
lost.
Nuclear weapons that are stolen,
nuclear weapons that are Adelaide,
right?
Nuclear weapons that are sold off the
back of trucks.
Right?
So what do you do about that?
Well,
people who believe in the
nonproliferation story will say,
well,
this is just another reason to prevent
more states from getting nuclear
weapons.
I said,
yes,
but what about all the states that
already have nuclear weapons,
including some that I'm guessing don't
really have very great can really
terrific controls.
So my view is our nuclear
nonproliferation proliferation policies
directed at the wrong thing and the
problem,
but we want to do is make sure that
nuclear weapons are in the hands of
states,
remain in the hands of states,
any state that has nuclear weapons.
We should be talking to them about best
practices to ensure that nobody sells.
Nobody steals,
nobody loses.
Nobody breaks.
Right?
This,
this requires a lot of application,
a lot of organization,
right you to be a responsible nuclear
power is hard work.
It took us a long time to learn how to
do it right.
We've actually in the past taught others
how to do it.
This should be the thing that we focus
on in the world from the nuclear weapons
problem,
right?
Because once nuclear weapons are not in
the hands of states,
in the hands of individuals or groups,
then deterrence becomes hard because a
rev,
a radical group,
a terrorist group,
a millennial group,
and I don't mean the generation,
I mean people who imagined some magic
moment where history is going to be
transformed,
right?
They,
they,
you can't deter.
You got,
they've got nothing that they value that
you can threaten or retaliate against.
Countries have many things they value
that you can threaten to tolerate
against.
These groups may have nothing to you can
retaliate against,
so it's very important to keep nuclear
weapons out of their hands.